this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery of the royal
armouries museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
on this week's episode he's going to be
checking out the weapons of 2017's
survival horror classic resident evil 7.
ah the pump action shotgun thank
goodness i said to myself when i
finally acquired this in the game it's
the best implementation of a pump action
shotgun i have ever seen
if you want to see more of jonathan
reacting to video game firearms make
sure to hit that subscribe button
and if there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you'd like to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comments section below
if you'd like to help out the royal
armouries museum and continue to support
jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
our old favorite the glock glock 17
ish you can see in the the preview
there's a lot of texture detail to it
and there's quite a lot of
accurate glockiness about it as well all
of the weapons in this game have been
sort of
idealized in a way or stylized rather
from their
correct look so this is uh generation
two glock 17.
yeah a lot of it's um correct if you can
say correct about about a virtual weapon
it's missing the
accessory rail on the front which is
appropriate to the gen 2.
so if i if i recall without um overly
traumatizing myself this is
a this is a policeman's pistol that you
pick up
and the the capacity is very low
capacity is 10 rounds
jurisdictions that restrict magazine
capacity in the states and elsewhere
will limit
magazine capacities to 10 rounds but
needless to say law enforcement are not
restricted in that way and so the the
capacity should be 17 rounds
but in terms of gameplay 17 rounds
especially if the enhanced handgun ammo
would make a lot of the other weapons in
the game
[Applause]
redundant
though this game has two of the more
iconic pistols
ever invented and incorporated into
computer games
we've seen the glock already and now the
m19 i think it's called
is actually for the most part
a colt 1911. whereas there are
departures on the glock model
the uh 1911 has features from
i think i'm right in saying this or if
not something similar
the smith wesson model 1006
so what i think they've taken from this
are
the curved trigger pivoted trigger
rather than the sliding trigger of the
1911.
the angle slide serrations point is they
have
derived the 1911 into something that's
slightly different and i'm not sure why
because there's no copyright reason to
do that and the 1911 is such an iconic
handgun that's that's gonna
even people who aren't gun nerds are
going to look at that and go
looks a bit weird
even though i only played the first
resident evil for about an hour
and then didn't come back until resident
evil 5 don't hate me for it
even i know the samurai edge pistol
from the resident evil franchise and so
it's as it's a as everyone will know
it's a tricked out beretta 92
and this version has a mounted accessory
rail
that the original beretta 92 doesn't
have but the modern versions do and then
you've got a sort of
an integral sound suppressor with a very
modern shape to it
we see a lot of different ammunition
types within video games these days
and as well as the normal and enhanced
handgun ammunition
we've got in the final bit of the final
level of this game
this iconic pistol and it's firing
something something different something
that has a
much greater effect thus turning what
would otherwise be quite a weak weapon
into something that can actually do
serious damage with each shot now that
has been experimented with
well poisoned ammunition certainly has
the nazis
and the soviets both carried out
experiments with
bullets containing poison payloads but
that was strictly poison that was not
necessarily
whatever these are long story short is
none of these
governments found that it was worth
pursuing so it's funny how
a sort of throwaway sci-fi gameplay
feature can connect with
reality when you start reading around
the subject
ah the pump action shotgun thank
goodness i said to myself when i
finally acquired this in the game and uh
luckily it wasn't just the
the feel the sound the look of the thing
that made it seem powerful
it actually is powerful in the game and
you know a headshot from one of these
things will will take down
your typical mutated beast thing and
this the pattern of shot although not as
wide as typically depicted in games
gives you a much greater chance of
actually hitting something vital
a load of 9 32 caliber balls from a
round of buckshot
is pretty devastating if the target is
not armored or
some sort of supernatural mutated freak
of science
in which case you might have to fire
twice when we say pump action shotgun
whether we know it or not we're probably
thinking of the remington 870
or maybe the mossberg 500 they are by
far the two most popular pump action
shotguns
in the world and this is in absolutely
standard civilian
sport shooting defense configuration
standard length barrel
standard length magazine tube and that
limited capacity but
sheer amount of power just works so well
in the game and the ability
to reassure yourself by topping up that
magazine tube before you
turn that next corner it's great it's
the best implementation of a pump action
shotgun i have ever seen
if i thought the pump action was a sort
of leveling of the playing field playing
through this game i should stress uh if
i sound a bit melodramatic about it it's
because i was playing it in vr
so uh the better the weapon the better i
felt and
a great upgrade to the pump action
weirdly because in the real world it'd
be the other way around
was the over and under break open
standard skeet trap clay pigeon shooting
shotgun
i i abandoned old faithful the pump
action
and i went for on the face of it what
would be a downgrade so instead of
having
between five and seven rounds of 12
gauge with a pump action
you you go down to only two rounds but
in the game
the same ammunition is somehow more
powerful out of the over and under
shotgun which is
needless to say completely unrealistic
but i don't think the difference
in power was so over the top as to
be immersion breaking
now this one's a a new one on me because
i have yet to play any of the dlc for
resident evil 7
and i must admit completely stumped me
because
although i know a little bit about the
airsoft world i have not seen this
particular
gun this isn't a purely airsoft design
it's almost a bit reminiscent of quite
reminiscent actually of the fn
scar rifle in terms of the receiver
architecture and the lines of it but
then the front end of it has super
aggressive
breaching shotgun look to it very sci-fi
so suffice to say
it is based on a real-world replica
firearm and it's not really a replica
because it doesn't exist
in the real world of guns so quite an
interesting
video game weapon i don't know if
there's enough recoil being
simulated in the way that's firing or i
guess uh chris redfield just
is a bit of a unit i get the the need
for this
in the dlc it's almost like going from
alien to aliens
in terms of the the volume of enemies
it's going to throw at you
and the need for a higher capacity
shotgun
that's quicker to reload the capacity
looks a bit high
12 rounds uh in a box magazine would
make it very tall
maybe they're staggering it 10 round
magazines are not uncommon on
competition practical shotguns now and
they do stick out quite far
i think 12 might be pushing it a little
bit
uh this game is a really interesting
mixture of
expected glocks 1911's pump action
shotguns
and the unexpected this being a good
example of that uh the pp19 bison
bison russian design completely derived
from the
ak assault rifle the thing that really
distances it from the ak
though is the magazine system as we see
in the footage it's a drum
but it's a helical feed drum so it's a
spiral of rounds
hooks on at the front latches in place
at the back
as depicted however what it doesn't do
is magically come off when you pull at
the back of the magazine because
as correctly depicted the in the 3d
model there's an ak style
magazine release button here or lever
here you have to press
to remove it the rate of fire is a bit
low it's a bit
chugging and it has a real meaty sound
effect that really calls to mind a rifle
rather than a
pistol caliber submachine gun the report
in game ought to be a little less punchy
i think
and the rate of fire ought to be higher
so the real thing is like 700 rounds per
minute
this is more closer to 500 i would say
here i come you're going nowhere
one of the more horrific scenes in the
game the weapon that we see in use there
is
clearly not real um it's a sort of
improvised flamethrower effectively
someone has designed and made it
themselves
i have picked up behind me a real world
flamethrower the lpo50
soviet design fairly classic backpack
flamethrower and the
three tanks which give you three shots
fire as a weapon obviously has a long
history whether it's a burning rag on
the end of a stick
ripley's flamethrower an alien it's
really more of a psychological weapon
for
i guess it that's how it worked on the
alien it's like instinctively
uh not keen on on fire as an individual
weapon as an
infantry weapon it's not tremendously
effective it has more of a psychological
impact
something that games don't really
illustrate this sort of does
is that you are not shooting naked flame
you are shooting
burning thickened fuel and it sticks to
the target so we do we do see that but
somehow i don't think i've
i think i've yet to play a game that
doesn't quite convey the sort of
how terrifying these these are as
weapons
this is something that i haven't tried
to find a parallel for because
it's so obviously homemade or craft
produced
as we say in this world it's like an art
it's a bit of art design
more than it is a practical weapon it's
got all sorts of bits on it that seem to
be cosmetic so it doesn't really
resemble any real world weapon
in terms of function break open single
shot grenade launcher it's a sort of
m79 filtered through the lens of jack
baker's twisted mutated mind i guess or
whoever made it
possibly lucas is supposed to have made
it effectiveness wise
obviously being a grenade launcher just
like real life
it is considerably more powerful than a
given projectile
but it's firing projectiles but with an
explosive payload of course
fragmentation
blast damage so something a bit more
fallout like
in in your resident evil i suppose what
the hell is this
what are their fancy toys
[Music]
ready for use this is obviously not a
not a gun of any kind but believe it or
not the
power fist glove thing from the from
this bit of dlc
sort of has a real world parallel and
it's uh sufficiently rare that we don't
have one
the sedgely fist gun was designed
for the seabees the military
construction workers working on
basically engineering constructing
things for defensive purposes in the
second world war a a
glove was designed it has a plunger
trigger so just like um jack is punching
the
the monsters there but he's using some
sort of energy
what the centrally gun did was just fire
a bullet the enemy got close enough to
your
construction vehicle but you didn't have
the ability to draw a pistol and shoot
you'd literally just
punch them and it would hopefully kill
them with that shot
if you'd like to support the work that
we do here at the royal armouries we
have links in the description
to how you can donate or become a member
we're also doing a series on our own
youtube channel on firearms so
do follow the link in the description
and check those out as well and i will
see you again next time
[Music]
[Music]
you